the following trailer is rated as for
spoilers
[Music]
in an entertainment landscape dominated
by corporate ip
three filmmakers are fighting to keep
cinema alive
spielberg
tarantino
and noen
but now with just his third film one
more name joins that hallowed list
the carpetron duke marriott le carpetron
duke marion
nope
saddle up for an old-fashioned black
cowboy ufo movie about black cowboys
making ufo movies the old-fashioned way
that pulls triple duty as an action
adventure
sci-fi horror
and salute to analog filmmaking no
electricity on top of peel's trademark
social commentary on how working in
hollywood is like being slowly digested
by a giant butthole in the sky
that tracks
daniel kaluuya stars as the other black
oj who owns a white bronco he's a horse
trainer who'd rather talk to animals
than people
and talks to people like their animals
whoa his sister emerald is your classic
cloud chaser i direct write produce act
i do a little singing on the side and
cloud chaser
who hatches a plan to chase a cloud for
cloud she may seem annoying and he may
seem like the oldest young man alive
but under the surface they're well
they're still both kind of dicks i can
monitor the feeds remotely myself if you
want free of charge hell no
thrill as the haywood siblings try to
capture ufo on film before it turns all
their ranch into ketchup
together with the help of gen z milhouse
she booked the pilot on the cw
left me
and a man who eats an ashtray full of
cigarettes for breakfast
they'll pull off a makeshift western
film shoot deadlier than alec baldwin on
a budget
shutter as jordan peel ranches up the
tension so slowly the fake outs are
scarier than the actual monster
because for most of the film it's a
cloud there
doesn't move exactly and that cloud has
been right there at least since i set
the cameras up i'll probably be looking
at the same damn cloud that would take
over the last six months that cloud i
move the god damage
with tons of windshots that are only
scary if you've never seen the happening
[Music]
here it comes
but what you don't see is scarier than
what you do
especially when your creature looks like
well the fries that close down in
burbank or in its final form squidward
having a maternity shoot
will someone please feed me a horse i'm
angry
steven euron caught a break in 2015.
now it's payback time he's a child actor
who watched his co-stars get beaten to
death by a chimpanzee and that's still
not his worst experience in front of a
live audience
in this subplot that explores the
predatory nature of hollywood and how
most of us are so emotionally stunted we
can only process trauma through old snl
references daryl hammond on augustaire
sherry o'terry scott wolfe is the host
he's me
but of course the star of the sketch is
chris god damn katana escorting you i
guess his business really does mess you
up
not schwing
so gay's in awe and a master of the
craft absolutely flexing on the audience
as jordan peele layers and jokes images
and references that will only really hit
when you watch multiple times keep our
heads up
on this one adds little character
details in the background like angel
mining krypto in his bedroom the dude
even snuck in an akira slide
okay look i don't have a joke here or
anything i just think he's great now do
the thing where people say the movie
title out loud that's funny
no nope nope nope nope nope
starring
payback horsemen
scream queens oscar baiting literally
jupiter ascending
alien versus redditer
they don't live
satino morph by curious
i hate every 8 by c from chimpan a to
champort e
and i see what you did there hey hey
what are we doing here hey hey
the little guys with the big eyes
[Music]
they schloop horses don't they
was gordy's home in nickelodeon sitcom
cause then the weird foot stuff makes a
whole lot more sense
don't think just do
do your ears hang low do they wobble to
and fro can you tie them in a knot can
you tie them in a bow
i'm on a pilgrimage to see a moose
praise marty moose